bonjour messieurs bonjour ça va on a
surtout c'est déjà pas mal
on a les deux sur de maintenance et
ailleurs ça va bien en main super beau
si moi je me mets à gauche je suis à
sept branches extrême droitière plus
jamais revoir et toi est ce curé de
l'eau alors être ou alors on peut dire
ce que vous voulez un verre de quelque
chose moi je viens de l'eau plati ou
blake de l'eau a coulé merci bien je
sais que cette salle de bal de faire
c'est finaux toronto may foot à 4000
personnes dans une salle les gens il a
été forcé de diane eric olivine nous
nous emballons pas pourtant c'était
vachement bientôt tu la sens entre
france mais question sont à chier comme
d'habitude nous vous serez très très
bien éclairé
je peux le pose est loin ici un ou un ça
va ce film est ce que je peux très bien
avant la bouche sèche et paniqué on dit
quand on est prêt je vais d'abord
m'adresser à jean-paul si vous le voulez
bien parce que on s'en doute rien
ressemblé gras rouges était très très
heureux quand ils m'ont appelé qui me
proposait de retrouver potes en fait
s'il convient d'être avec eux parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils s'intéressent à ce
que tu dis sont là quand on tombe sur
des dialogues comme ça on se dit pas
comment je pourrais modifier ça demain
parce que c'est une cancer jouer ce
vraiment merdé à jouer cette merde mal
écrite au contraire ah non là c'est vrai
avec ceux ci ça arrive
merci infiniment super merci qu'est-ce
qu'il va falloir essayer de voir c'est
tout
c'était bien les aider un peu ça ne vous
convient pas à tout prix apprenez prise
a dit regardez la façon de mieux moi
donc voila merci merci ca vite c'est
bien ça pour voir
merci merci